l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de madame catherine cros cassia à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt la
parole mes chers collègues merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
ministre des transports de répondre à ma
question qui concerne l'école nationale
vétérinaire
de maisons alfort qui vient de perdre
son agrément européen est dispensée par
l'association européenne des
établissements d'enseignement
vétérinaire depuis le xviiie siècle
l'école vétérinaire d'alfort est l'une
des plus prestigieuses de nos écoles
vétérinaires en france et en europe à la
fois pour la qualité de sa formation et
pour son patrimoine immobilier
historique
c'est un site unique en france son
centre hospitalier universitaire
pratique 35000 acte chaque année pour
les animaux et les nouveaux animaux de
compagnie
tout en assurant les urgences
vétérinaires 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 dans une structure moderne
inauguré en 2009 sur plus de 3600 mètres
carrés ces trois sites spécialisés et
kim grands animaux et faune sauvage on
faisait jusqu'à présent un centre de
référence vétérinaire nationale et
internationale toutefois l'école ne peut
faire face à des frais d'entretien très
lourd né à ses bâtiments historiques
c'est pourquoi le directeur a décidé de
différer la visite d'inspection de
l'association européenne des
établissements d'enseignement
vétérinaire faute de pouvoir mettre aux
normes le site et nomme notamment la
réalisation du pôle à ces risques
biologiques cette décision a entraîné la
perte de l'agrément européen de l'école
nationale vétérinaire d'alfort bien
qu'il s'agisse d'un agrément et non pas
d'une accréditation
universitaire c'est un signal très
négatif est préoccupant pour la portée
du diplôme de docteur vétérinaire ainsi
que pour tous les étudiants en cours
d'étude
des répercussions sur la réputation de
l'enseignement et sur la recherche
vétérinaire française qui jouissait
jusqu'à présent d'une excellente
réputation en europe sont inévitables la
france dorénavant ne disposera plus que
de trois établissements reconnus par
l'association européenne des
établissements d'enseignement
vétérinaire seulement 45% des
vétérinaires français sont actuellement
formés dans l'hexagone affaiblissant
notre rayonnement universitaire au
regard de l'allemagne ou du royaume uni
monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais savoir quelles sont les
mesures envisagées par le gouvernement
pour que les travaux nécessaires soient
effectués d'ici la prochaine inspection
et permettent à l'école vétérinaire de
retrouver son agrément européen et de
gouvernement prévoit-il une double
tutelle des ministères de l'agriculture
et de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche pour réaliser plus facilement
tous ces travaux merci chaque collègue
pendant l'été monsieur frédéric
cuvillier michal transports de la mairie
de la pêche merci monsieur le président
messieurs madame les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice catherine
occasion
madame la sénatrice mon collègue
stéphane le foll est actuellement à cet
instant
donc je vais être précis
alors je vais le plus fidèle possible à
la réponse qui m'a bien voulu qui m'a
demandé de bien vouloir vous vous
transmettre il était interrogé donc à
l'instant à l'assemblée nationale
l'école nationale vétérinaire d'alfort
constitue un élément clé du dispositif
national de formation vétérinaire
essentiel dans la protection de la santé
publique et de sécurité alimentaire nous
tenons dit stéphane le foll a réaffirmé
que l'école nationale vétérinaire
restera sur le site d'alfort dans ce
contexte le rétablissement de sa santé
financière est une priorité l'objectif
dans la réflexion sur la création d'un
pôle vétérinaire nationale et d'enrichir
l'offre de formation vétérinaire
d'adapter les formations aux nouveaux
besoins d'inscrire notre dispositif
national de formation conformité avec
les référentiels internationaux les
efforts que l'école nationale doit
consentir ne se feront pas au détriment
de la qualité de la formation c'est
ainsi c'est aussi pourquoi cette école
fait l'objet d'un soutien particulier
depuis plusieurs années l'école
nationale vétérinaire d'alfort est
l'établissement qui a bénéficié de
toutes les écoles sous tutelle du
ministère chargé de l'agriculture du
montant le plus important de crédits
d'investissement versés ces dernières
années elle a reçu 22 millions d'euros
2009 de 2008 à 2012 en 2013 dans un
contexte budgétaire contraint du
ministère de tous les ministères mais
également du mystère stéphane le foll
800000 euros supplémentaires sont
disponibles pour des travaux de mise en
sécurité en effet ces financements
conséquents ne peuvent être consacrée à
des dépenses de prestige ils doivent
être utilisés pour des investissements
indispensables à l'école pour la
sécurité des étudiants la qualité des
enseignements et qualité de la recherche
le nouveau directeur de l'école
nationale a engagé un plan de
redressement qui commence à porter ses
fruits manifestement avec une réduction
de moitié du déficit le retour à
l'équilibré financier devra se faire
avec un impact social le plus réduit
possible en dialogue permanent avec la
communauté de travail de l'école
nationale dans ce cadre il a été décidé
de reporter la visite de l'association
européenne des établissements
d'enseignement vétérinaire initialement
prévue en 2013 cette accréditation n'a
pas de valeur juridique et la suspension
provisoire de l'accréditation de l'école
nationale vétérinaire d'alfort lié au
report de la visite n'aura aucun effet
sur la reconnaissance européenne du
diplôme de docteur vétérinaire délivré
par l'école nationale ces diplômés
pourront donc toujours s'installer
librement sur le territoire de l'union
européenne
par ailleurs vous évoqué la possibilité
d'une co tutelle des ministères de
l'enseignement supérieur bull et de
l'agriculture pour cette école il couvre
convient de préciser qu'un tel
dispositif ne serait pas une solution
pour esi de résoudre les difficultés
financières précise stéphane le foll en
revanche une coopération est engagée
entre les deux ministères dans le cadre
du presse du pôle régional
d'enseignement supérieur paris est par
ailleurs l'installation prochaine du
siège de l'ansès sur le campus l'école
nationale renforce et pérennise son
positionnement comme pôle de référence
en santé publique et en santé animale le
ministre de l'agriculture il est très
attaché et très attaché aux bénéfices
que peuvent retirer les étudiants de ces
collaborations enfin monsieur stéphane
le foll nommera prochainement une
mission qui fera des propositions sur la
valorisation du patrimoine de l'école
nationale vétérinaire d'alfort dans le
cadre du pôle régional d'enseignement
supérieur notamment au profit du
logement étudiant voilà ce que je peux
vous livrer comme réponse la plus
précise qui soit que ma demande et ses
fans aux folles de pouvoir vous livrer
merci monsieur ministre par le thème
madame catherine procaccia merci
monsieur le ministre alors je veux vous
rassurer ma question était un peu
différente votre réponse est aussi un
peu différent des donc adapter
effectivement à ma question sur les
diplômes sur le positionnement de
l'école vétérinaire
j'apprends a effectivement par votre
intermédiaire qu'il va avoir une mission
sur cette école vétérinaire tout à
l'heure à l'assemblée nationale monsieur
le foll a confirmé qu'il acceptait une
table ronde de tous les partenaires
parce que certes si l'état et les
gouvernements précédents ont raccordé de
l'argent à l'école vétérinaire cette
école elle date elle a des bâtiments
historiques et les vrais problèmes ce ne
sont pas des rénovations de prestige
mais des rénovations indispensable parce
que dans ces bâtiments historiques et
bien il y a des salles d'enseignement il
y a des salles de travaux et l'âge
apprenait par exemple que le bâtiment un
des bâtiments n'a pas été rénovée depuis
135 ans et là n'aura même pas de
réparation des fenêtres donc je
n'appelle pas ça effectivement des
réparations de prestige en tout cas je
suis contente de savoir que cette école
fait encore l'objet d'attentions du
gouvernement la double tutelle n'est
peut-être pas la solution
mais en tout cas ce sont des bâtiments
historiques peut-être faudrait-il
trouver
auprès d'autres ministères des
subventions puisque les bâtiments ne
peuvent pas continuer déconne ne peut
pas continuer sans avoir ces appuis
financiers il ya un seul élément qui
m'inquiète un tout petit peu dans la
réponse qu'on vous a demandé de me faire
c'est d'évoquer l'impact social le plus
réduit possible même s'il a le plus
réduit possible ça signifie qu'il peut
avoir des conséquences effectivement en
termes d'emploi sinon les autres
éléments étaient assez rassurant et je
vous remercie de votre réponse